-How are you?
-I'm good, man. I'm good.
-You're in the building
for "SNL."
-I am, yes.
-First time hosting.
-Yes, yes.
-You were saying backstage
"dream come true."
How are your nerves?
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
I'm terrified.
-Yeah.
-It's a lot of risk
with, um, some reward.
-Yeah.
No, I think you land it,
people will --
You'll hear about it
for a long time.
-But if you don't land it,
I think you'll hear about it
for a long time.
-Yeah. Well, the worst that ca
happen is people come up to yo
and say, "Hey,
I saw you hosted 'SNL.'"
[ Laughter ]
And then that's it.
That's like the end of it.
-I used to get that
'cause I do --
I do plays in New York
and you get --
If you get a good review i
the "Times," you get voicemails.
15 voicemails, you know?
Or you get one voicemail.
And it would be, "Hey, dude.
There's a picture of you
in 'The New York Times.'"
[ Laughter ]
-You -- You said
you started out here.
You had an early theater troop
in New York City
when you were a very, very young
actor, yeah?
-Yes, I did.
-What was the name
of your first --
-Clearly, you've done
some research.
-Well --
-This is not exciting
to talk about.
Fantastic.
-We found out about it
'cause you've talked about i
in the past.
This was not
a hit theater troop?
-No. This was not
the rise to fame and fortune
It was called
the Eyases Ensemble.
-Uh-huh.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It a very -- It's got
a very pretentious etymology
In "Hamlet,"
there is a line where --
Yes, thank you. You're welcome
There is a line where they say
"There is an eyrie of children
sir, which cry on the top
of question, little eyases."
-Uh-huh.
-And so we were like,
"We're young."
-Yeah.
-"We do plays."
-It's such a bummer
'cause eyases sounds like
you're saying something wrong.
You know, it doesn't, like
roll off the tongue.
It's like, what were you guy
trying to say?
-Yeah.
-And you --
Did you not get reviewed wel
at Eyases?
-We, um --
We did not get reviewed
at all until --
until we got one abysmal revie
from "The New York Times."
-Wow.
-Which trampled all of our hopes
about the geniuses
that we thought we were.
-Yeah. That's rough.
-And then I went to a life
of, uh, soap opera after that.
-You did.
-I went to "As the World Turns
right after that.
-How many years
were you on "As the World --
-3, 3 1/2 years.
I played a cop.
Surprise, surprise.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-My career has really changed.
The roles --
-They were, like, "Hamlet"
and then just cops,
cops, cops, cops, cops.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]